[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
nous sommes bien amusés cet après midi
au oui nous sommes allés dans la forêt
accrocher notre petit à une très grosse
branche par la forêt était plein
d'oiseaux
vous croyez qu'ils viendront dans l'eau
ni l'autre j'en suis sûr nounours et ils
vont couvet les étrons tôt naîtront
trois joli petit oisillon je te sent
vite le dire à nicolas et pimprenelle ce
qu'ils vont être contents mon échelle et
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop c'est
pas ses secrets et puis c'est trop chaud
seul de le nier dont la forêt coucou les
cochers ne vient au stade a déjà couché
ce que vous êtes sort n'a pas envie
d'être sage tu sais à des soins d'un
prenez-le merci on est enrhumé alors
maman mes amis ou lit
moi j'ai bien envie de me lever aux noms
devaient rester bien longtemps
votre maman a raison et demain vous
n'aurez plus de rue vous est amusant
vous les grands phonique dans la même
chose mais non c'est très bon la
tisanière non bois mon petit nicolas tu
très gentil droit c'est que moi j'aime
pas ça moi non plus et moi n'ont pu mais
écoutez moi bien les enfants
si vous êtes bien sage je vous promets
que demain nous ferons une pelle rond
nous danserons la capucine à écouter
dans son loft piscine diop de pas chez
nous
y en a chez la fois ce deal mais ce
n'est pas pour nous jouer et bravo les
enfants vous avez tous pu vous voyez ce
n'était pas si difficile allons fermer
vite vos jolies sion
demain nous allons bien de vous amuser à
damas north la jette un oeil le
beau 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour voir les enfants embrasser bien
fort votre papa et votre maman n'oubliez
pas de faire votre toilette de bien vous
laver les dents et allez vous coucher
sagement à voilà notre nounours qui
remonte dans son look top us in older
photo kgs et fidèle compagnon au wi fi
dèle patron nicolas et pimprenelle m'ont
fait très plaisir
ils ont bu toute leur tisane comme des
grands aussi demain doute en serons
ensemble oui envoûte venue des enfants
cette boue rêve à deux mains
oh
on
auj
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]